[Music]
Robert Spencer here for jihad watch a
program of the David Horowitz Freedom
Center and for the Center for Security
Policy recently news broke about two
Muslim brothers from Texas Armin and
Omar Ali who joined the Islamic state
and their parents who lied to the FBI
about it the Dallas news reported a
Texas college friend who asked that his
name be withheld because he didn't want
to be associated with Armond said he
arrived at UT Austin as a pretty normal
kid but he became religious during his
second year and gradually grew more
orthodox Armond was no longer playing
soccer basketball and video games with
friends he was spending more time at the
mosque he said so once again we see a
Muslim becoming more observant in its
long and then joining a jihad terror
group there are so very many examples of
this just recently a Muslim in Canada
who stabbed a woman in the throat
explained that he did it because he
started listening to the Quran and there
are many other jihadis who have
justified their violent activities by
pointing to Islam Abdullah Azzam the
co-founder of al Qaeda explained jihad
was a way of life for the pious
predecessors Salaf juice Saleh and the
Prophet was a master of the Mujahideen
and a model for fortunate inexperienced
people the total number of military
excursions which he accompanied was 27
he himself fought in nine of these
namely Badr who hood Almer I see the
trench cur Isaac Aybar the conquest of
Mecca hunain and Taif this means that
the messenger of allah used to go out on
military expeditions or send down an
army at least every two months Egyptian
scholar Nasser Hamid Abu zaid's stated
if we follow the rules of interpretation
developed from the classical science of
quranic interpretation it is not
possible to condemn terrorism in
religious terms
it remains completely true to the
classical rules in its evolution of
sanctity for its own justification this
is where the secret of its theological
strength lies the mastermind of the 9/11
attacks Khalid Sheikh
and his fellow 911 defendants wrote many
thanks to God for his kind gesture and
choosing us to perform the act of jihad
for his cause and to defend Islam and
Muslims
therefore killing you and fighting you
destroying you and terrorizing you
responding back to your attacks are all
considered to be great
legitimate duty in our religion Taliban
terrorists baytullah Massoud said Allah
on 480 occasions in the holy quran
extolled muslims to wage jihad we only
fulfill God's orders only jihad can
bring peace to the world
Times Square car bomb ta terrorist
Faisal Shahzad said jihad holy fighting
in a laws call course with full force of
numbers and weaponry is given the utmost
importance in Islam by jihad Islam is
established by abandoning jihad may
Allah protect us from that Islam is
destroyed and Muslims go into inferior
position their honour is lost their
lands are stolen their rule and
authority vanish jihad is an obligation
and duty in Islam on every Muslim yet
despite this and so much more in the
same vein authorities persist in
claiming that Islam has nothing to do
with terrorism we even see the claim
that jihad 'is know little about Islam
and care even less our mana lease
trajectory in Texas tells a different
story
also which mosque in the Austin Texas
area was Armand Ali attending has it
been investigated has the FBI tried to
determine whether Armand Ali got the
idea to join the Islamic state from what
he was taught there almost certainly not
the FBI remains determined ly clueless
regarding the jihad terror threat if we
had any investigators who were patriotic
and worth their salt that mosque would
be thoroughly investigated and agents
would be closely monitoring its
teachings and attendees note also that
Omar Ali was working in strict accord
with the Quran quote he emailed her
again that is his mom in October 2014 to
say Allah tells the Muslim to fight kill
and exile
those who wage war against Allah
and His Messenger that's according to
court records the Quran says indeed the
penalty for those who wage war against
Allah and His Messenger and strive upon
earth corruption is none but that they
should be killed or crucified or that
their hands and feet be cut off from
opposite sides or that they be exiled
from the land that is for them a
disgrace in this world and for them in
the Hereafter a great punishment that's
chapter 5 verse 33 so all this is in
complete accord with Islam I'm Robert
Spencer
[Music]